bonsoir tout le monde au nom du ciel
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça c'est
notre nouveau sapin de noël j'ai eu chez
lady foot locker et paix n'ont pas du
tout aimé
je le trouve répugnant qu'est ce que
cette chose fait dans ton salon
ils voulaient pas perdre de temps à
l'acheter je voulais juste prendre du
plaisir à noël cette année une multitude
une mère une mère ne prend pas de
plaisir elle donne du plaisir c'est son
boulot de maman c'est tous les états y
deux ne risque pas de donner à qui que
ce soit le moindre plaisir je suis pas
sûr je moi je le trouve geôliers mais
qui êtes vous et pourquoi donner votre
avis ne sois pas désagréable c'est jessy
je vous ai présenté même je suis fatigué
de cette conversation
si tu crois une seconde que je vais
laisser des manigances de feignasses
gâcher le noël de toute la famille tu te
mets le doigt dans l'oeil ma petite venu
mettrait hors série
tenez je vous ai pris des cartes itunes
vous allez adorer mam ce même âge et
qu'il faut parler de leur faire des
cadeaux
c'est cool chérie tu as vu la déco du
sapin ce sont des petites chaussures je
le jure devant dieu je vais abandonner
sur le parvis d'une église
[Musique]